uh talk about the music man what do you
got out right now what do you got coming
uh I just dropped a song called a single
no Nick calling no name dropping I've
been at like I think it's like 800k in
like two weeks that's a lot of views
yeah I just y'all Gucci man I saw that
one shout out to Gucci how the [ __ ]
that happen I don't need [ __ ] no bro
I saw the guy you don't know how how it
happened that fool just send you a song
and say here this is yours what happened
like my manager hit me up
he was like he always had like he always
brung Gucci up type [ __ ] right you feel
me like he like hell man Gucci good
friends type [ __ ] so I never really like
you know pay no attention to it because
I'm like [ __ ] you telling me like I'm
gonna get to work with this right right
so
one day I'm like I'm he texting we
talking and [ __ ] say like what you uh
doing today I'm gonna head to the studio
right now says like um I got something
for you he was like um
I'm gonna send you a beat and I want you
to uh here's like do something to it
type ships right all right you feel me
knowing but sometimes like when he send
me stuff like that
I try to stir away from the Shoot Em Up
bang bang [ __ ] because you never know
who yeah what he gonna do with it right
right that's fair I can't I gotta show
versatility of course so it's like
my all right so I did it and I sent it
so he was like man he was like this [ __ ]
fire so I'm like you dead ass like
because sometimes I ain't gonna lie be
said guessing he's like yeah this [ __ ]
fire watch this type [ __ ] he was totally
talking so
about to send me the verse back
so like I click that bit a bit said
Gucci
what the [ __ ] that's crazy so I remember
him like he kept bringing Gucci up right
remind you so I'm like damn so this way
he probably had to be asleep this whole
time so I hit a song like what the [ __ ]
it's all like I call my brother know I'm
like man what the [ __ ] out of song Gucci
Mane they like man stop lying so like
man I swear to God I got a song Gucci
man so boom
I get around my brother though I play it
and like everybody just like sitting
there like
after the song end like everybody's just
not seeing it couldn't believe it like
yeah like and then my big brother don't
they grew up on Gucci like yeah so it's
like they sitting in that bed like boy
what the [ __ ]
that's so crazy like nobody just
couldn't believe this [ __ ] like we just
all sat there in silence like is this
[ __ ] real
well I mean and and you got the video
Yeah that would threw me too so that's
that's like I'm sure a lot of people I'm
not a lot of people but I mean look
getting them versus one thing we're
getting the verse with the videos crazy
that threw me all the way out because
when I met him
like he's like he was like what's up Jay
that like
I'm like [ __ ] like I can't I'm keep it
real like because I grew up on Gucci
like of course my daddy doing all that
[ __ ] so it's like this [ __ ] a legend
basically like the [ __ ] basically yeah
for sure yeah like for sure that so he
like what's up Jade I just him saying
like what's up Jay like what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] I used to look at you on the TV
and I was like four five years old by
the way you're aging me so crazy right
now yeah
that's what'd your dad say I don't even
talk to my dad well there's that yeah
just like you haven't talked to him for
a while uh yeah that's fair we won't get
into your family problems don't worry
cap show is not for family issues oh no
I don't have family issues it is I don't
this [ __ ] yeah my dad right now who else
is on your project
uh which one and when you say you just
dropped oh no that was just two singles
I was just two singles okay so when's
the album coming out all right oh
soon because you're here for a reason
soon it's coming out soon but before the
end of the year
probably okay in the beginning of the
new year all right all right
is that the name of the album knew me no
it's called don't [ __ ] with me later
Jesus but it's gonna be don't you know
what don't [ __ ] with me later I like
that I thought you were gonna just say
it's called don't [ __ ] with me that one
word changes the whole context of what
the [ __ ] title is imagine you put an
album card it's called don't [ __ ] with
me I'm like damn bro we know time you're
on
oh [ __ ] don't [ __ ] with me later it's
like oh I get it yeah [ __ ] with me now
because you're gonna have to [ __ ] with
me later yeah yeah you feel me like